bonsoir philippe est mêlé merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
campagne de vaccination donc qui
continue en espagne et on pense déjà à
vacciner les plus jeunes alors pas du
tout la même stratégie que la nôtre où
ils vont passer en anton dernier est ce
la meilleure solution pour vous pour
freiner l'épidémie
écoutez ici l'objectif c'est à nouveau
la saison estivale et c'est vrai que
l'espagne envisagent tous les scénarios
pour permettre la réouverture de ses
plages et de ses stations balnéaires au
plus grand nombre
elle a été l'une des premières à
proposer le passeport sanitaires pour
les futurs déplacements en europe
elle est aujourd'hui la première à
vouloir anticiper effectivement la
vaccination des jeunes populations et l
a mise en place effectivement un certain
nombre d'essais et on peut voir et bien
d appel aux familles pour effectivement
trouver des volontaires parmi les jeunes
de 6 mois à 18 ans mais pour le médecin
vous êtes est ce que c'est la bonne
manière justement pour freiner
l'épidémie où c'est une solution
davantage économique
alors vous faites bien de le souligner
c'est vrai que le débat économique n'est
jamais loin et ce pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord effectivement parce que
l'économie espagnole repose
essentiellement sur le tourisme est une
nouvelle saison estivale qui seraient
sacrifiés serait vraiment absolument
catastrophique pour le pays
ensuite parce que même sur la thématique
du développement des médicaments pour
enfants
il y a toujours aussi un enjeu
économique vous savez beaucoup de
médicaments ne font pas l'objet d' essai
thérapeutique pour les enfants et c'est
pour ça qu'un certain nombre de
médicaments ne sont pas disponibles
à la posologie adéquat pour les enfants
et on ne se lance effectivement dans des
essais thérapeutiques pour les enfants
que pour deux raisons d'abord si la
pathologie effectivement concerne
largement la population infantile et
ensuite si effectivement l'impact
économique en termes de populations
impactées est important et on se
retrouve à nouveau également sur ce
sujet là dans une effectivement dans une
thématique économique également alors il
faut souligner quand est plutôt bonne
nouvelle d'ailleurs pour pour tout le
monde le faiseur et à 100% efficace sur
les adolescents à partir de 11 ans c'est
bien ça oui c'est vrai vous avez raison
on ne s'interroge plus beaucoup
maintenant sur l'efficacité des vaccins
on sait que quels que soient
effectivement les vaccins ils ont une
efficacité qui est significative pour la
population le seul doute aujourd'hui
effectivement qui peut être permis c'est
le recul qu'on n'a pas sur ces
vaccinations et on aura évidemment que
dans 18 mois à deux ans mais personne
aujourd'hui nos comptes est
effectivement la production d'anticorps
après l'administration de ces vaccins
l'espagne il faut le rappeler aussi
philippe emmanueli à a payé un lourd
tribut avec ces jeunes au niveau des
écoles avec un confinement à l'époque on
se souvient extrêmement strictes et
peut-être aussi ce traumatisme on a
peut-être plus envie de fermer les
écoles et c'est bien compréhensible en
espagne oui si on n'a plus envie de
vivre ces restrictions que vous pouvez
vivre encore en france d'autant plus que
l'espagne a fait ses preuves
vraiment elle adopte une forme de
confinement effectivement très
chirurgicale qui respecte les petits
commerces qui permet aux gens de
continuer
à vivre je dirais dans les rues de mener
en quelque sorte une vie normale mais
effectivement avec deux limites la
première limite c'est le couvre ce qui
est à 22 heures ce qui est pas une heure
déraisonnable par rapport aux 18 heures
qui ont parfois été imposée en france
et puis on a également cette adhérence
de cette adhésion de la population aux
mesures élémentaires de distanciation et
ici les gens respectent avec beaucoup de
comment dire l'inspecteur vraiment
effectivement les mesures de
distanciation ça pas empêché le ministre
de la santé de passer une nouvelle loi
il ya deux jours qui s'appelle la loi de
la nouvelle normalité
on sait pas trop bien ce que ça veut
dire mais en tout cas c'est la nouvelle
normalité en espagne et 7 cette loi
effectivement va imposer malgré tout le
port du masque sur les plages alors
effectivement ça ça c'est pas très
agréable alors vous dites les espagnols
adhère mais il faut préciser
vous l'avez un petit peu dit que
certains commerces restent ouverts qui a
les barres sur tous les restaurants
notamment pour le week-end de pâques
déjà peut-être que ça voilà ça détend un
peu la population et du nez quand vous
voyez nous conte refaire le tout est ce
que vous vous expliquer en tant que
médecin cette incohérence pourquoi en
france on ferme pourquoi en espagne en
nous pourquoi on fait autre chose en
allemagne ça vous semble pas
complètement incohérent vous avez tout à
fait raison stéphanie de mary le
problème c'est que cette épidémie est
gérée à coups de polémique
et ce qui est dommage c'est
qu'effectivement on n'arrive pas je
dirais à à prendre en compte tous ces
problèmes de façon plus consensuelle à
se rassembler autour des solutions qui
seraient les plus favorables pour tout
le monde aussi bien les acteurs
économiques que la population que tous
ceux qui sont impactés par cette
épidémie
et c'est vrai qu'on
on ne voit pas où est la cohérence quand
un pays mais le couvre-feu à 22h l'autre
pays mais le couvre-feu à 18 heures un
pays ferme des bars l'autre lot ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que ici
effectivement en espagne les gens ont le
sourire
on ne retrouve pas les tensions qui
peuvent être décrites en france dans la
rue et c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment
d'avoir une vie à peu près normale sans
doute l'ouverture des bars et des
restaurants tibétains en espagne merci
finit pas aimé lui ai dit d'avoir été
avec nous en direct donc de barcelone un
rappel que vous êtes médecin libéral
français merci à vous